michael walker's been good at times but
then there's been other times where he's
given up maybe a few too many runs so
let's see if the offense can carry the
way again today austin hayes batting out
of the two spot he went over five
yesterday
2-1 pitch hayes lashes this one into the
alley and right center field this gets
down mullins waved around third he's
gonna score heading to second austin
hayes back-to-back doubles and a great
beginning for the orioles against waka
and the rays it's one to nothing as
mullins and hayes each with two baggers
mancini heading 258 57 runs
a liner right back to the mouth at
second they got to get the double play
raka almost defensively got that glove
up there to make that catch and then the
presence of mine to turn and look at
second and they double haze off second
base the thing for mount castle as for
many young power hitters the strikeout
he struck out 101 times most on the team
here's walker throwing two two slice to
right caught by v dal bruhan
kevin cash couldn't stop talking about
his defensive play yesterday and the
range that he has and that one right
there he picked it off before it could
get past him and into right field so the
orioles get back-to-back doubles to
start it and then two batters later walk
us out of the inning end of half in
saint pete alexander wells is going to
make the start for the orioles today
after keegan aiken was put on the il as
part of a coveted protocols it'll be
randy oroz arena to lead things off
against alexander wells this is his
first major league start
there's a high drive back into deep left
and that baby is gone
home run on an 0-1 pitch
[Applause]
[Music]
gets the raise even
the rose arena is starting to get hot
monday got hotter last night and you
can't get off to a better start than
that first career lead-off home run for
randy arose arena and austin meadows
will come up to the plate the oak two
fastball outside corners strike three
called
so he gets meadows on three pitches for
the second out of the bottom of the
first inning they're two on base
after a pair of walks and here's choi
who stands in from the left side
2-2 pitch chased and missed strike three
wells climbed the ladder so he strikes
out a pair in the first
issues a couple of walks too and gives
off a homer joey wendell
toward the gap
right center field gonna go all the way
to the wall
he is gonna be waved around
wendell's gonna dig for three and he's
gonna make it without a play
joey wendell with his second triple of
the year and the rays take a two-to-one
lead
brett phillips
talented outfielder for the rays 2-1
rays leaning nobody out pitch in
fast ball strike three phillips was
looking for something else
he got the express and didn't pull the
trigger so wendell at third with now one
out and the ever dangerous arose arena
wells delivers
and that is chopped at third it's
grabbed by lay but throw coming to the
plate wendell was going he's tagged out
by wins
so the second it was chopped leyva got
it and they threw out wendell trying to
come home and score
he's leading two to one on the wendell
triple it's a one-run lead for tampa bay
valancia to start off the third pat
valleca out to left field a drive from
belenka and a first pitch home run in
the third
pat valencia with an ambush of michael
watka and there is the second home run
for valencia 2021
to tie the score at two now you gotta
face
power hitter and trey mancini but the
ending still alive
three and two to count runner will be
going on this next offering there he
goes in the pitch swung out and missed
strike three
so they get mancini swinging and that'll
do it for baltimore here
in the third but they get a run on the
solo shot by pat felayko two down a 2-2
ball game bottom of the third g-man choi
at the plate 2-2
choi swings and loses his bat in the
process so it's a strikeout
bat throne but alexander wells gets out
of the inning after three orioles two
raised 2. castle grounded a second base
his first time up
first pitch attack ryan mount castle a
deep fly ball and there is the first
home run in july for ryan mount castle
back-to-back innings the orioles hit
michael walker's first pitch out
valencia in the third and mount castle
with a titanic blast to the fourth to
put the o's back in front wendell with
yesterday off tripled in the second
inning
off of wells today 02.
and he gets him fastball up high wendell
swatz he comes up empty two down
austin wins fouled to the catcher
mahir's only timeout
and that's
he had him out in front let's see if
the top of the order can get something
started as they see him for a third time
they do and rosarina drives one way up
into the air again to deep center field
mullins all the way back to the wall and
randy's done it again a solo homer to
tie the game it's three to three
first pitch of the inning his 13th home
run of the season the face brouhan who's
gone over two in the game manning second
base today for tampa bay now the payoff
strike 3 on a fastball
3-0 three strikes and brujahn rung up
another punch out for alexander wells
here comes mount castle he had the
opposite field home run
back in the fourth inning righty on
righty matchup whistler throws
and he swings and pulls this one down
the left field line it's a fair ball
rounding third heading to the plate is
mancini rbi single this time ryan
meltcastle on the seesaw we've been the
entire game orioles now have the lead
four to three mount castle homered
earlier and now he's got an rbi single
to put the o's up by a run
with a walk and fly to left pitch in
swing and a miss lal goes down on
strikes number seven for alexander wells
yeah perfect pitch outside point we're
on over three he's been from the right
side all afternoon 2-2
bruhan chops a fastball playing in
domingo leyva the throw to first is in
time
as he charges gets cole salsa out of it
5-3 after seven orioles lead the race
this is now loaded with two outs
ureas at the plate swung out and popped
up in the shallow left tough play franco
going out a rosarena coming in and randy
is going to make the catch and that will
retire the side so a little scary for a
moment now the last chance for the raise
is austin meadows
and the pitch line drive up the middle
base head here is mahi to score the
tying run here is kamar to score the
winning run and austin middles has
delivered and the rays have won the
series and walked off the orioles five
to four